alors lequel des trois de bonne foi de
jacques prévoit va vous donner la bonne
version 2 attention du mot mauviette m à
uv ou de thé savez tous bien sûr ce qui
est une mauviette espace jean pierre
mais nous avons un premier candidat il a
pas l'air à voir comme ça il ya imposant
1 700 type monsieur wii wii sports
pratiqués vous emballe en bas c'est
toujours un peu de ce qui l accusait
alors du skate blizzard est également
très bien monsieur donc en écoute vos
trois définitions faudra choisir la
bonne monsieur voilà alors la première
définition de monsieur l'origine
inconnue origines de mauvais temps cette
année par paul préboist alors le mot
mauviette et est apparue au 16e siècle
c'est un diminutif de mots vis mon vif
en appeler movis les alouettes n'est ce
pas huppé au moyen-âge dans nos 'rien'
alouettes superviser avant la movie ce
joli mot vis mais qu'en dit avec des
pommes petite alouette huppés qui était
jeune donc chétive malingre un peu
souffreteuse maladie movie ce n'est ce
pas par l'extension et diminution disait
mauviette été transporté après quand on
a vu quelqu'un de faible de indiqué
mauviette rachète une mauviette
mais la véritable origine c'est viennent
de ce mot movie ce qui désigne les
alouettes huppé au moyen-âge et en le
transformant mauviette pour parler d'une
alouette et qui était plus chère du bâti
de l'ale un peu chère suzanne c'est à
vous lasser tout ça mais c'est pas
écouté la larme à l'oeil non en réalité
c'est un mot d'origine latine
ça vient du mot malva c'est un nom de
plantes
c'est une plante qui était mauvais
qu'avait la propriété de soigner à peu
près toutes les maladies les maladies de
tous les malades qui étaient des gens
totalement chétif fatalement souffreteux
est le nom de cette plante est devenu
d'abord move est parce que les thèmes
moraux et jolie et puis après ça s'est
transformé en mouvement
est avec sa s'approchait des à la fois
des malades et de la plante donc c'est
une plante d'origine latine ça n'a rien
à voir avec les alouettes
il fait de prébois voyez vous voilà donc
maintenant la troisième origine celle de
jacques blanc viennent c'est pas du tout
du latin c'est un mot du vieil anglais
mauvais et qui veut dire maigre et qui
signifiait et qui fut repris par les
français qui ajoutaient le diminutif est
synonyme de petit et qui donna par la
suite personnes maigres chétive
mauviettes
voilà je récapitule pour vous si vous
voulez bien monsieur alors pour paul
préboist vient du diminutif movie ce qui
était le nom de l'alouette huppé au
moyen-âge et les petites salles ouais tu
paies et on les a appelés ensuite des
mauviettes
c était tout petit susan gabrielle au
vient du latin malva qui voulait dire
mauvais puis ensuite mauvais tu es puis
mauviette c'était une plante qui servait
à soigner les personnes malades et pour
jacques prébois n'est pas d'accord du
tout avec ses deux partenaires vient du
vieil anglais moreau qui signifie maigre
alors qu' à la bonne origine des trois
fois zarla 2 ouazar l'a26 taire susan
gabrielle aux plus jeunes cabrio non
mais c'est pas ça du tout c'était pour
passer vraiment logique et bien en
réalité
en réalité c'est paul préboist j'avais
la bonne réponse assurée n'y a ni de
végétal j'étais du règne animal
ma vie c'était vraiment dur a pas tout
recommencer
et c'était effectivement la loi du pays
n'est qu'une moyenne
je pensais pas finir jean pierre alors